[Applause]
okay so what I want to do before I get
into Scotland closures is just give you
the briefest tour of some of the rules
of what how how it works inside a
function
so when we're defining a function and
remember this area here is the region I
want you not to confuse with properties
of the function
from this curly brace to this curly
brace that's where we put the lines of
code that should only run when we invoke
the function but it has nothing to do
with property so check this out
I might want to pass something into a
function a function is something that
does work depending on some some input
and that's where we put that's where we
give names to whatever gets passed in
if this was a blender that would say
whatever fruit they want to blend right
but instead I'm just calling it insulin
and then we would do some work on that
input so I can make it all uppercase and
then log it up
notice the yellow code does not run
until in this case it won't run at all
and here it will run in between logging
example one and example two
so the question is what can we pass in
there
well I can tell from the code here that
it's expecting a string so I might pass
in a string and down here we have a real
value up here we just have a name for
anything that gets passed into the
function
here's where I want you not to be
confused
what do we expect this to log
uh in the pink
that's right
I wish this was mine
whatever
don't think we know what it is
you don't think we know what input is
so input
is up here
so what would you expect to show up on
the screen as a result of this log line
okay
um
I'm not sure all right well the word
input here
seems to be a variable lookup
and a lot of people would like to think
that this means we're going to be
talking about whatever was passed in as
input here
but because of scopes
the variables available in between these
two curly braces are not available
outside of these two curly braces
so
this is not going to work at all because
there is no variable input out here in
the global scope
can anybody think of a fix for that some
way that we can log the input think of
what you might type down here to yeah
um you would call
we would want the function of the terms
you would rewrite the function so that
it returns its input yeah that's one way
to do it
here's what a lot of people propose
they say well we'll use dot access on
the function object
and this is that thing that I was trying
to repeat there is no overlap between
the stuff in between these curly braces
and the idea of properties on a function
object
so using dot access is just kind of
grabbing at a tool and being like maybe
I can use this to get access to it the
answer is no you can't get access to
input from outside these two curly
braces under any circumstances because
scoping rules are there to help you
you're not allowed to break those
scoping rules using some other mechanism
like dot access especially considering
dot access talks about properties and
Scopes have to do with function bodies
and there is no overlap between the two
two the two concepts are never thought
about using the same mechanisms
it doesn't also work to use brackets for
the same reasons
uh and this stuff we can kind of skip
past because it's less related disc
closures
uh but
if we have a function fund that returns
to
I'm gonna put some extra white space in
here this is pretty equivalent to if I
was to use this function if I was simply
to type it out again in place of the
variable name that stores that function
so here I now have not one but two
different functions that do the same
thing and the second one notice I am
just invoking immediately
this is called an immediate indication
it's not too useful right here I might
as well just set VAR 2 equals two why
would I have all of that other stuff
there
it's useful in other circumstances we'll
we'll see in a minute what I wanted to
make clear was that saying fun paren
paren
right this construct
is almost exactly equivalent
to this construct just typing a whole
function out and invoking it immediately
there's very little difference two
parens
means invoke whatever is to my left
yeah
so these two parens right here are going
to invoke the function on their left
just like
these two parens right here
are going to invoke the function
referred to by Fun on the left
that's a really tricky concept for some
people with any questions yeah
like you did before it yes it makes it
smaller
but let's see what we can do
uh Tas could you help me by getting four
chairs and lofting this up on four
chairs
okay so for now it's full smaller but at
least high enough you can read it I
think
no problem so
there's only two more people to hold it
up while the other people put the chairs
in
not all speakers get Tas
both speakers just have to go over there
and do it themselves in the middle of
the talk
it's not funny
[Music]
too good
okay
[Music]
engineering we're chairs
[Laughter]
and you see the bottleness yeah okay
thank you awesome
okay so uh
both of these two situations are the
same calling the function the variable
that stores a function with two parents
right next to it and calling a function
that is defined in line parenes just
being run the function on the left of
the parenthesis
there's a syntactic ambiguity that I
think is important to take note of
briefly and that is the difference
between the first and the second pair of
parents because they look similar right
the first set is where we put where we
give names to inputs
that is the function
input list
the second one
is where we actually provide values that
should be given those names
zooming back
to this situation
here we give names to whatever gets
passed in it says some fruit or other
here we pass in a value and we say
operate on that
thing
operate on the string High
call whatever string comes in input
so this is a strawberry and this is a
main for whatever fruit comes into the
blender right
here we have both of them appearing at
the same time
right next to each other and it's
important to know that they mean
different things
are there any questions about those two
types of parens and their meanings
yes absolutely it would look much the
same to the passive value as it would if
you were using a variable name followed
by parents you would just open these
parens and and
in the space between these parents you
would put some value like the number
three or the string high in this case
we are giving names to the inputs and
then we aren't doing anything with any
input so it would be kind of odd to do
so but you could imagine doing so in
other circumstances if we were to edit
the rest of this function too then it
would make sense to start passing things
in here
we also use it to evolve all the
functions
invoke other functions
these parens can only invoke the
function immediately on their left
so it can only invoke this function
right here but we can use other parens
to invoke other functions
let's get one more question about the
two param of the ambiguity between them
Etc
yeah also parameter to the first print
could I
if I were to put something in between
here it would not be passing anything it
would be giving names to things that
were passed in because if you look up
here this is where I give names to the
inputs to this function right does that
does that look familiar these parents
are where I give names to things being
passed in
zooming back momentarily I give names
like input to whatever gets passed in
same is true here I give names to
whatever is passed in same is true here
this is just where I give names to the
inputs to a function great question
yeah we had a question yeah
you're absolutely right
if we make if we made this thing return
itself we made this function return
itself we can put any number of parens
after if we wanted
I kind of want to do that at the console
you guys up for that yes
return
s good
right so when I call Foo what do I get
it I guess Boop
when they call Foo and then call the
result
I'm calling Foo
so I could just do this all day
that's kind of cool
okay
so up above here I could of course
immediately invoke the function but then
this variable would be named for you
because it's no longer storing the
function
what is its story
what is this variable this misnamed
variable now story
it's destroying
it's storing two it is starting too
going back here
this variable was named two because it
stores the return value
so when we put parens here this should
be named two as well
because the result of this entire
expression which is a function
definition followed by an immediate
indication the result of the entire
expression is two
and so this should be named something
too lightly Duo
but now down below this code here
doesn't make any sense because the the
permense that were there before
don't make any sense you cannot call the
number two
all right this last part I'm just going
to give you a hint because we're not
going to use this feature too much
you can refer to inputs
using the arguments object arguments
just keeps an up-to-date list of the of
the arguments that got passed in
an argument to a function is very much
like a variable a local variable within
the function with the exception that
this doesn't have a value right now you
need to assign
whatever the first input was so this is
an array-like object that refers to the
first
that that has a list of the arguments in
it including the first one here which
would make this work this whole thing is
equivalent to that whole thing
any questions about that
yeah so in that case the argument issue
the reserve yeah arguments is a reserve
keyword
that
reflect whatever was passed into the
function the word argument appears with
it
all right
if there are any more questions I'd be
happy to answer them
otherwise I'm going to tell you about
Scopes and glows
cool
it's always go
what do you think of when you hear the
word scope what is your working
definition of Scope when you just like
here
um whatever
whatever variables we have access to yep
very useful working definition
any other thing you think of any other
like ways that you think about the word
scope
in the scope when you create them
so I'm hearing a lot about access areas
of our code where we can talk about
variables
there are actually two definitions of
the word scope
uh and they map approximately to the
idea of lexical scoping and dynamic
scoping
but there are basically two ways in
which people use the word scope
one way that they use the word scope is
to talk about
the regions of your typed code
that have distinct access rules from the
other regions so while I'm typing in
this section between these curly braces
I can talk about variable a b and c when
I'm typing in these curly braces over
here I can talk about variables x y z
and they won't generate errors
but if I talk about X over here then I
will generate an error or if I talk
about a over here I will generate an
error does that make sense that's one
way that people use the word scopes
another valid use of the word Scopes is
the data structure that is generated at
runtime
to store those variables
so one was the area of your code you can
type in and the other is this runtime
data store
those are very different and here's why
a runtime data store
there will be many instances of a
runtime data store for every region of
the code
for every distinct scope region in your
code
you could imagine there being many
data stores generated because you're
going to run that function many times
the scope is generated by a function in
JavaScript
so let's take a look at the data storage
version and I'll show you how it maps to
the code in a moment
here we have
A visual representation
of a region like a fenced-in area where
we're storing a collection of values
those values have labels on them
variable names
a bunch of key value pairs does this
remind you of anything
what is that reminisce of
object it feels very similar to objects
you've got a collection of values they
have keys in them
there's some name spacing so they can be
collected in one and then there's other
Scopes elsewhere
how are they different how are scopes
and variables different what Scopes and
objects different
one of the most interesting is the way
you access this is probably the most
relevant way
you access a uh variable using an
identifier you say log the temperature
temperature does a variable lookup it
looks it up in a scope
There are rules for how you can what
what identifiers you can talk about and
which ones you can
those are scoping noise
when you want a property off of an
object you need to use a DOT so dot age
notice we had to use variable lookup to
do the user to find the user object in
the first place but once we had a user
object we were able to use dot eight
I'm going to change the slide right now
because
I can make this even clearer
maybe that's polarity
in this example
I never even did any variable lookup I
just accessed the age property with a
DOT
so up here we have an identifier lookup
on a variable and it does all it
interacts with all of the scoping rules
and here we have dot access which
interacts with all of the object access
rules these two worlds are very similar
they have similar rules but they have no
way of interacting
right
it's kind of like uh
it's kind of like um
two different planets in two different
solar systems
in two different universes
where all the laws of physics are the
same
so the laws governing
key value access are pretty similar here
as they are here but you will never be
able to interact there will be no
interaction between these worlds even
though the rules governing the two
worlds are very similar and people get
this confused they try to access
properties just by talking about their
their key as if it was a variable day
or they try to do dot access on the
functions
local variables in that example fun dot
input remember how I said people want to
type fun.input that's trying to use
property access which looks similar but
lives in a different Universe in order
to get access to local variables
okay
is that a bad thing is it a bad thing to
access to try and access the local
variables of a function using a DOT it's
bad in as much as your code won't run
but other than that it's fine
no it's not bad it's just doesn't work
so this hopefully
canoe some of the work of making clear
the difference between a scope and a and
an object
specifically the fact that you can't
get a reference to a scope
so my first function called give me an
object give me object returns an object
that has X Y and Z as property as keys
right
it returns that object immediately so
someone calling give me an object
could
operate on it they could iterate across
that object name all of the keys there
they could
mutate it they could add one to it they
could do anything you can do to an
object in the second example give me a
scope we create local variables a b and
c and I ask the question what could you
return
such that someone calling give me scope
would then be able to operate on the
scope
they would then be able to edit the
scope insert new variables
iterate across the variables to find out
which ones were present
the answer is there is no such construct
in JavaScript there is no way to get
access to that scope
this is exactly how distinct the two
universes are the universe of scopes
although there are runtime Scopes being
generated all the time and they have
these key value pairs
kind of like properties on an object
they are in such a different universe
but you can't even get references to
these scope collections does that make
sense
are there any questions about that they
are like objects that are useful
for storing collections of things but
you don't give direct access to them
what is the only way you can interact
with a scope and modify a scope and
interact with it at all uh in the Green
Street sunglasses
yeah
what's the only way you can think of
interacting with this job
the data contained by
what's that
uh you can't use that notation good
guess dot notation is how you get access
to Dot and bracket notation or
equivalent and it's how you get access
to properties on an object
but a scope stores variables
and does not give you any mechanism for
for getting a reference to the scope
and so the only way you can interact
with the data in a scope or a scope at
all is to talk about its variables
you use variable access you talk about
an identifier and you assign to it or
you access it and console log that or
something by talking about
by talking about an identifier
from within the lines of code that
you're allowed to you're interacting
with the runtime
scope object but that's this really kind
of sideways angle that you get on
interacting with scopes
so the answer here is that there is
nothing you can return such that the
person calling gimme scope has a
reference to the scope
are there any questions about that
I put an asterisk here because there's
one exception to this rule
and it's most useful if you can believe
that there is a complete
difference in these two universes where
Scopes and and and and objects are have
no overlap unfortunately there's a tiny
overlap
there is an object that represents the
global scope
it's only one of many scopes
but it's one object it's one scope that
has a corresponding object the global
object
has properties on it with the same Keys
as the variables that are available
within the global scope
so to talk about
the globalobject dot Foo is the same as
to interact with the variable Foo if the
variable food lives in the global scope
so the rules we're about to learn about
Scopes only pertain to Scopes the rules
we just learned about objects only
pertain to objects the one exception is
you get this special thing that can kind
of be both at once
trying to ignore the existence of the
global object for now because it can
only confuse that I say it now so that
if you are familiar with it you're not
sort of like working to reconcile this
lie I just told you that there's zero
over that there's a tiny bit of overlap
that I want to set aside for them
uh scope nesting it's possible to build
a scope inside a scope
and when you talk about a variable in
the Interscope
if it is not available
if you if you for example if these if
this green area
maps to a section of my code that is
inside another scope section
then from within the innermost area if
I'm talking about name
it will fall through
and look up name here so I can talk
about the name variable in the outer
scope as well as the Interscope
I mean the Interscope is inside the
hours so that's fall through we'll see
that take place and then it's the case
that you can have many sort of you can
create an arbitrary nested tree
structure
of scopes
uh inner variables mask outer variables
that share a name so here we have the
variable name is Charlie in the global
scope and inside the variable name is
Alex in this bluescope if I'm inside
this blue scope and I try to talk about
name I don't have any way of talking
about the outer
Global name
as soon as I type the word name the
identifier it thinks I'm talking about
the local one
so that is masking
lastly and this is the most important
part of the Scopes section
Scopes are created every time you call a
function
exactly as many times as you qualify
when
and I'm talking specifically about the
scope
objects
a scope is not created once per function
definition that would be lexicoscope
that would be the Scopes
that you can see when you read your code
a brand new scope is created every time
you call a function
so
how much
how many Scopes would you expect there
to be in the sort of gray shirt
yeah
uh how many Scopes would you expect this
code
to have it if I ran this
this whole thing
either
in the back nope behind me yeah
uh
is that
seven Scopes yes because we've called
the this function three times we called
this function three times and every
every program starts with a global scope
what we would what we would not say is
the case is that there are two scones or
three scopes
there isn't a scope for this function
and a scope for that function
that would be the other definition that
we started the one where we said
sometimes people using the word scope
mean the region of your code that you
can type within that has distinct access
rules from
can I get a water
I'm talking a long time uh
we would not be talking about uh the
regions of our code that have different
access
rights
we're talking about the fact that when
we call the the sum function the first
time
two and two were given
names A and B
and so we ran this function in a given
scope
and uh
and then we ran it again
we wanted the second run of the function
to talk about a very different a and a
very different B from the first run
and so a brand new scope was created
where those names meant different things
this is a very important distinction
the second time the sum function runs
these names must have different meanings
and so we have to build a brand new
scope object for that second run of the
function
there are as many scope objects
as there are invocations of a function
when does Scopes get destroyed
JavaScript is a memory managed language
meaning you don't have to worry yourself
very much or ever about garbage
collection which is nice uh but it kind
of obscures the answer to your question
yes they do get collected eventually the
way that that happens is internally
JavaScript is keeping track of uh
what variables
you could possibly talk about in your
program and if you can't possibly talk
about a variable any longer than a
garbage collector let's go
so let's let's write a quick program
that exemplifies how Scopes come into
existence as objects distinct from
scope regions
in our code
we're going to write a story generating
program
that writes stories in the Classic
Hollywood tradition Boy Meets Girl boy
loses girl boy finds girl
so here I've written my program
uh you don't have to read it because
we're gonna go we're going to go through
it line by line we're going to examine
what happens
in the runtime in memory as these lines
of code are being evaluated
and Quinn
if you can get this running on your
machine
uh we can demo it uh
we've written a tool uh Quinn was one of
the primary developers that helped write
a tool that renders this stuff
automatically but we'll look at it in my
slides first
uh
the coloring here is to indicate what
scope region on the
in in the textual layout
each each region has its own color so
the outer purple part is global and then
the inside the story function you have
this Blue Area the win and fail
functions get their own color that's the
lexical scope in use of the word scope
each color is a different lexical scope
what we're going to do is run the code
and as the code is running
we're going to build up the in-memory
Dynamic scope objects
so when the program starts running it
just builds a global scope before any
line of code runs at all
and this red dot is your interpreter
your interpreter looks up variables from
some context depending on where you're
currently what you're currently
executing so that so the Red Dot
currently has access only to variable
defined in the global scope
since we haven't run any Electric Code
yet there are no variables in the global
scope
rut bro
no
okay hang on
foreign
the first line of code
and we're not going to examine how the
random hero function Works we're just
going to assume that the browser gave us
this
function that generates a random heroic
sounding string
so over here
some things are going to change in my
in-memory lab what would you expect to
change if you were given this
presentation how would you update the
picture of the world as a result of this
line of code having run
exactly so it's going to
it's going to be a variable named hero
and it will map to some heroic sounding
string girl and
then we're going to run the next line
what is the next line of code in the
black
the layers of function in the global
scope yes the next line of code spans
from here
all the way down to here
and this stuff in between is kind of
ignored
that code doesn't run but this joint
line of code builds a function object
that's this value here starting with the
F and ending with the curly race
and stores it in a brand new variable
story
so it's pretty similar to the line
before it
the value stored here is some function
object
and now we're ready to run the story
function and only then when we jump up
into the body of that function
so when you run a function a new scope
object is created I'm creating a blue
scope here that relates to the blue
section inside the story code
The Interpreter moves in there and
starts doing variable lookup from within
that scope object
I'm going to dim out this box here and
move the focal line of code to the first
line of story
the next thing that's going to happen is
very much like what happened in the
global scale
we're going to create a new variable
Target
it's going to get a random Target
assigned to it
in this case CEO so the story is going
to be about a girl and a CEO
the
CEO string is stored in a variable that
is local to this scope
and not in the global scale
we then create a win function and a
failed function and we call all three of
them we call both of them three times
so first we call the wind function
that creates a wind scope inside the
story scope The Interpreter moves in and
we run the first line first line creates
a local variable
and then we do
variable lookup
the process by which
we look up each of these three variables
it's going to be slightly different
right the first one hero well that's all
the way out in the global scope right
so
it falls through out of the
green scope out of the blue story scope
and all the way up to Global
but then action is found locally and
satisfied and CEO has to fall out let's
go
and so this output array that we're
building here is going to include and
this is just like a picture of what your
console will have it at the gray area
down here
it's going to include girl Trump's CEO
as the first
as the first string
The Interpreter moves out because we're
done running the win function
and at this point
it's impossible to imagine getting
access
to the value in trumps
right
you cannot posit The Interpreter can
trust
that no future code could possibly talk
about the value trumps
there's no way that future code has
typed anything that could mean give me
access to whatever the action variable
stores
and I would propose that you can't
imagine code that should mean that
so since The Interpreter has detected
that no future code could possibly run
that could be talking about the variable
action
it garbage collects that variable on the
scope that it's in
you may think
well we could get access to the action
variable again right
how could we do that
it seems as though we could do that how
does it seem as though we could do that
what do you think doesn't it seem like
we should be able to get access to
action again
so run time is local uh sorry this
action the one in win so we ran when we
garbage collected it
it feels like we should maybe be able to
get access to action again
perhaps just by running wind a second
time
right it would be a new action
s that is the thing that I want you not
to get tripped up by when you run a
function a second time you're generating
a new scope because you want a whole new
environment to run that function in
functions by Nature right are supposed
to be able to run in isolation they're
supposed to be independent of all the
other times that that function is run
and all the other code that isn't that
function you want to trust that a
function will operate
as if it's the first and last time it's
ever operated
that's how functions are so magically uh
simple to think about you don't have to
remember the history of how that
function ran in the past
kind of like a
uh the difference between
a
a blender a blender operates the same no
matter how many times you run the
blender
which is different from like a
switchboard right
as you as you connect things in a
switchboard you would better understand
the new configuration of the switchboard
it's going to operate all differently or
a president president of the country has
to operate in a brand new environment
that is based on a long history of stuff
the president has to consider
in order to be a good president you have
to consider a lot of context
it's very difficult to be a president
it's very easy to be a blended
so the second time you're on a win we're
going to get a different scope
if we run the fail function we get a
unique fund a unique scope for fail we
run a random failure we get injures
we do variable lookup on Hero action and
Target
and it gets girl injure CEO
girl injures CEO
and then we run the win function a
second time
creating a brand new scope and that's
why we get in brand new value
there is not just a new value assigned
to the the action variable
there is a brand new variable that has
no relationship with the old variable in
a brand new scope that has no
relationship with the old scope
and when we're done doing all of our
lookups
of course we can garbage collapse and at
that point we're done running the whole
function
we can garbage collect that too
if we were to run the story function the
second time we would get a whole
parallel Fleet of values
are there any questions about the
diagram as we've seen so far
all right so once C is Purge
references and laws
so the question was once the scope has
been garbage collected or all of the
variables in the scope has been have
been garbage collected
you can't get access to them anymore
right and I would say that that is
actually sort of a tautology because my
definition of garbage collection for
JavaScript is The Interpreter notices
that you can't get access to things
because there's no way there's no
there's no lexical way to have typed
something that gives access so the
definition of garbage collection to me
entails you having lost access
you lexically lost access
the rest of your code couldn't express
the idea of accessing those variables
those values and so the garbage
collector is just kind of doing the
natural way to apply Thing by by
cleaning up the memory that you don't
have any way electrically of talking
about anymore
does that make sense
uh
cool
if you're ready if you feel as though
that stuff made a lot of sense
and I'm willing to take one more
question on this so that we're standing
on a good foundation we could talk about
closures they are very confusing
so are there any questions you guys want
to ask before we do that
cool I have to revert
to my actual version of the sludge
hmm
I have a question yeah
I think maybe one case
like that win function that you have
if it's outside of
um switch
I guess
how to change the nature of
what I guess what the fall through
variables are accessed I guess
because it I think in cases that it
accesses upon that runtime it doesn't
depend
s necessarily on where you're running
the function it depends on how the
function can find better things
like
if I put
Target
and it will always goes and then I put
wind in the global school as well then
even if I run away inside the storage
position uh I'm just noticing that the
amount of code necessary to understand
your question is high enough that once I
do understand it uh it would take some
work to explain it but if you type your
code out I will either explain it in
person or flash it up if I can if it
seems like something that I'm going to
learn from okay but yeah definitely type
that out and I'd love to explore yeah
all right closures I'm not going to give
you the definition of a closure right
now because it's kind of misleading and
confusing and difficult to wrap your
mind around
instead I want to leave you
to invent enclosures yourself they are a
pretty reasonable imp uh addition
to a language that has function options
once you have the idea of functions
being passed around your system you
would probably ask yourself the
questions we're about to ask eventually
so let's just do that
I've got a variable here it's an array
I'm going to store stuff in it don't
worry about it
I've got an outer function
that I'm going to run so this code is
the continuation of that code and then
it runs up here okay
column two
so this outer function I run it
immediately
now whatever happens in here
what I'm going to do inside that
function
I'm going to push
new functions into this
array
so basically what I'm doing is the weird
little
uh
back flip well JavaScript backflip we're
doing
is creating a scope that is within
another scope right while I'm not
creating the dynamic scope I'm creating
a lexical scope but I'm creating this
lexical scope
inside this other lexical scope
and then I'm running outer which has the
effect of generating a brand new
function
so I run outer and I add a brand new
function to this energy
if the code makes sense
notice that this function is going to be
around even after outer is done so I
could call inners
Sub Zero
right inner Sub Zero is the first
element in the inters array which is a
function these two parens invoke that
function
so by calling outer I generate a brand
new function I put it in the array and
then I invoke that function that was
created
what will happen right now
kind of nothing right because there's no
code in here
there's no code inside the inters
function so let's
let's make some variables to make this
interesting
we've got a global variable a
we've got a very inner variable that's
entered to this inner function
C and we have one in between from Outer
and these three variables feel rather
different to me one is clearly going to
be available to everybody
that's a a just changes over time it's a
global variable it's intuitive to
everyone again right and C is rather
intuitive to everyone here when we run
inner Sub Zero we get a brand new C
right
if we run it seven times we get a brand
new C every each of those seven times
but B is kind of in limbo
is be like a global variable that's
accessible later or is B like a local
variable inside a function and that's
the that's the question that you have to
answer as a language designer when you
invent closures
if I were to log a b and c as part of
how this function operates what would
the user expect to see
so
before we reveal the answer I'd like to
examine your intuitions
as I recall you have experience in other
languages and JavaScript is a little bit
newer
and so I think you would be a great
person to ask what are your expectations
am I wrong okay
yeah uh what are your expectations as to
what this should log here
is going to be
just just the a department
so a was defined on the second line of
our program to be zero so it spent very
little time in an undefined State okay
and nothing ever changed a to be
undefined so unless there was a was
referring to some local variable
a would be undefined notice we have
scope fall through falls through out of
this function out of that function all
the way
a sub zero B is zero C is zero okay
all of them can be zero because we've
never changed them they're going to be
set to zero of course yep
we call hitters
why is B still around
by the time you call inners why is B
still around yeah great question great
question
uh
because
this inner function
needs the ability to talk about all the
variables
that are lexically available to it fall
through says that if this function can
run it can talk about a in the global
scope it can talk about C in the focal
scope and it can talk about B
because B is like lexically available to
it
right
so
this would make this would be very easy
to understand
if we were just calling this function
the line after it was created
while the outer function was still
running
what makes this really interesting is
that we're running the inters function
after the outer function has finished
running
and the question we have to answer is as
a language designer what do we make B
talk about when we run when we run a
function after
after its context has completed running
the answer that JavaScript gave was
that that graph that I showed you
we don't garbage collect variables as
long as functions can still talk about
them
that's the answer
if I were to put plus plus in front of
each of these variable names
then you probably expect that they would
have incremented to one right by the
time we log in each of them was zero and
now they're all one pretty
straightforward
but what happens when we run it a second
time and I'd love to come back to you
because I didn't give you a chance to
really talk about your expectations and
I think your expectations are going to
be super interesting here
a
the global variable a started out as
zero and then we ran inners and it
incremented a login right
so it made it one
now we're running inners again what is a
going to be
yeah
well notice we have this plus plus here
and it's a global variable so its state
was probably lingering keep forgetting
so yeah two two okay now what about C
what would we expect C to be here
we expect C to be one because it's a
brand new variable C that gets generated
and it starts out at zero and then it
gets incremented to one
and now my question is what is B more
like a or c
how will how do we expect B
to behave
oh my goodness
similar to a which was two but still but
only the value one there I'm just saying
it's on the outer so I'm talking about
so I'd say one
so you think it's one because it's
similar to how C behaves is created
afresh
not for the looks of this function I
would say yeah that is one well check
this out dinners we're calling inners a
second time right so the thing that is
incremented is anything that enters
is has lasting effects on it the things
that are still one are the things that
are being generated right now as a
result of calling units things that are
changed by having called Enders so C is
a brand new C that's why it's one
is not a brand new B I can tell because
outer has run only one time ever in
history right there okay so yeah
much like a which was a global variable
there's only one there's only one V in
existence
right
we call outer one time creating one
scope that stores the variable B so
there's a 1B variable in the whole
program right now
foreign
this is closure
the lingering of this burial not the
lexical variable you're reading on the
screen but the dynamic variable that got
created in that data store when we
called outer right there the whole scope
for outer got created
and it stayed in existence while we
while we ran inners a first and a second
time
it's the same B variable which is why
it's changing just like the global
variant
all right let's do a thumbs check a
thumbs check is an exercise that we do
at school so that I understand how clear
a concept has been what I would like you
to do is report to me using your Thumb
Thumbs Up means very positive thumbs
down means very negative report to me
your level of confidence that you could
explain closures clearly
to a land
uh they don't have to understand it but
you have to trust that you said it right
confidence that you can correctly State
what a closure is just that I wouldn't
nitpick
some hugely
wrong aspect of what you said Thumb in
the middle means
I don't know kind of
thumbs down means no way bro thumbs up
of course my new photos when I came in
can we use slides no slides uh
all right mostly thumbs middle this is
great this means we needed we need to
drill into this
someone with their thumbs milk
in fact everyone who had their thumbs
built take a moment to take the
confusion you have the sense of like oh
I feel like I would fail at it and then
take that blank and just say it out loud
turn it into a question in your mind I
need you to formulate that into a
question for me
no more respect variables
great so the the uh the question boiled
down to
if we use the sentence I said which was
the language keeps variables around for
as long as there are functions in
existence that could talk about those
variables
that's the sentence I'll say one more
time the language keeps variables around
for as long as there are functions in
existence
that could talk about those variables
there might be a shorter way to say it I
hope but I want to examine uh I'll come
right back to you is it about that
sentence
well so
maybe it's just uh to me it's a
confusing closure and scope because what
you're describing to me sounds like
scope ah right
and this is pretty close to the question
she's asking as well so given the
sentence that the language will not
clear up variables
as long as there are functions that can
talk about those variables in existence
we could accidentally interpret that to
do with like
lexical Scopes so the this function here
has access obviously to its own scope
function body associated with it in an
electrical sense if I was looking at
this and not running the code I see this
as as one function right but this is not
one function
this is as many functions as we create
by calling outer a brand new function
comes into existence every time we run
out these are two different definitions
of the word function two different
definitions of the word variable there
are as many B variables
at runtime as I have run the outer
function
at program definition time however there
is only one B variable
right we are saying something rather
different when we talk about the
variable at program definition time
versus one of the many B variables that
come into existence at runtime
sure if I may just put a put a
punctuation at the end of that that
tries to answer the question
uh
the sentence
the language won't garbage collect a
variable
by which I mean a runtime variable
until there are no functions in
existence by which I mean runtime
function objects that can talk about
that variable
it's very important that we know I'm
talking about runtime functions and
runtime variables but when I run outer a
second time
I could certainly create a brand new
function that has access to a newbie
when I run inners a second time I create
a new C
there are going to be a multiplicity of
C variables each one is garbage
collected immediately as soon as
the inner zero function finishes up
so now so what you're describing in my
head makes total sense I'm trying to
determine exactly what enclosure
represents it sounds like it's an
executable block
like what you were showing in your
previous Slide the execution block that
I think of the scope I think is what
you're referring to as a closure no uh
a closure there's a definition coming
right up here a closure is a function
that has access to variables of
functions that have finished
a function object not a not a lexical
function like right the word f u n c t i
o n ending the curly race here is a
visible piece of code function I mean
the runtime function object if it
retains access to variables the
functions that have stopped that have
already returned then uh then it's
included
cool all right
so we're going to explore this in more
detail
but I would like to
I would like to make sure that the
definitions we've given for closures so
far make sense
and that we have an opportunity to
really stand on Solid ground with that
stuff so all of you thumbs middle folks
and thumbs down folks
and you put your curiosity or confusion
into the form of a question
Loosely understanding what it does I
think I'm missing the larger picture
yeah you're saying
why is it the case that closure is a
useful thing to have built into the
language at all
so
I can give you a general answer and I
can give you a specific example I want
to start with the example because I
think you'll connect more but then I'm
going to generalize it to the to all
cases the specific example is if you
have if you want to register an on click
Handler in your browser application and
you do so inside a subroutine of a
subroutine of a subroutine yeah
that Sub sub subroutine
that has
lexically it talks about variables all
the way out to Global right it talks
about local variables but it also talks
about ones in the scope right around it
and right around it you're registering a
click Handler that's going to happen
some point long after this whole block
of nested code has completed right the
code runs the Handler gets registered
and then time progresses
and the user clicks a thing The Click
Handler fires and the question is
how is the code inside that click
Handler supposed to behave
it talks about variables not just local
to itself and not just Global but
including variables from the Scopes in
between
so since we know for sure that the user
is going to click long after the code is
run the registered The Click Handler
asynchronously in fact after all of
those functions have have returned we
must answer the question
how does this click Handler treat the
variables it refers to
from functions that have returned
does that seem like a reasonable use
case or is it not quite answer your
question I'm sorry apologies I can come
back to you if you
um let me give you the general case uh
answer and then we can connect it to The
Enclave uh and and you tell me whether
there's room for uh more clarity the
general case is
is actually on the screen already
anytime a function
anytime we are going to retain access to
a function
after it's containing context has
finished drowning we have to answer the
question what do we do when it tries to
talk about variables from it's
containing context
so in The Enclave example
The Click handling function was much
like this nested inside a function that
had been called and some things happened
that let you had a boot function the
boot has like a a setup subroutine and
the setup subroutine has to run uh you
know twice for some reason and you call
it twice and then it calls some stuff
and you've got all these variables and
then inside the subroutine of the setup
you've got
the The Click Handler being attached to
the logout button
it talks about something from setup it
talks about something from the boot and
it talks about something from Global
those functions have finished running
someone clicks log out they're talking
about the function that got registered
at that time it has references to
variables from functions that have
completed so the language says you know
what we're going to leave those in
existence we're going to let them evolve
over time just like Global variables do
so when you run this and you'll run out
of for the second time and you run
energy again uh we're actually going to
do an example where we run out of a
second time so uh it's difficult for
people to track on code that isn't on
the screen so since I already have that
one I'd like to wait till we get there
but by all means do do ask this question
when we've got it on the screen and also
I think I feel like we had one that I
was supposed to answer for you later did
that ever yeah
ah all right as soon as we break I want
to answer objects with objects inside
yes
is the closure function yes
it's said to close it's said to have
closure scope access to variables
thermometer
you kind of repeat with a different
explosion because I'm trying to describe
it is it the code of the function that
you talk about or is it like a runtime
instance
the way most people are going to use it
it is the instance of a function
the inner function that has access to
Outer two variables from an auto scope
now looking at this code
I could read it and interpret the fact
that this this inner function will be a
closure whenever it's created that many
times that it becomes created and will
create many closure instances looking at
it I might call it a closure that'd be a
different use of the word
for all code constructs there's like a a
a part-time definition of every
construct and a runtime definition of
every bounce drug but generally when we
say closure we're talking about a
runtime
right
now I would want because it sends access
to the global variables uh great
question does outer have closures of
access to the global variables generally
we don't use the word closure to refer
to a function that has access to global
variables because Global variables are
kind of accessible through
even without the mechanism even without
the mechanism of closure it looks so
similar that I don't take the issue with
your calling at that but no one does at
all of that
as an example of why that's not the case
you could have two different files
in node there is a global object that
you can hack
and two different files will have access
to two global global objects even though
lexically they do not have closure
access to those global variables
any others yeah yeah I think uh now it's
right here in the middle right into my
whale
because in my mind
between
what's a program what's what's uh what's
his scope and enclosure there are two
ways you could say that I'm sorry I
don't know but I feel like I know your
your question is is there how can I
discern the difference between a closure
and a scope
um
some people use the word closure a
little differently than the way that I
have and it means the same thing it's
just they're talking about a different
noun in this whole you know population
of nouns I've used okay you've got the
definition I gave enclosure is a
function that retains access to
variables from other functions that have
finished running right but another way
you can say it that might be that
certainly talks about the same thing
even if it isn't technically accurate uh
you could say that a closure is a scope
that remains in existence
after its Associated function has
completed running in this case someone
would someone would use the word a bit
differently to say that
the outer function has a closure which
is its scope
which is still available because the
inner function has access to it these
are two sides of the same point
the function uh this this inner function
here
that we retain access to
and the scope that it retains access to
as a result
there are two sides of the same kind of
like idiosyncrasy were examining
so it wouldn't be insane to call the
closure the scope itself a closure scope
but I believe the technically the most
correct definition and I could be
mistaken about this is that the closure
is the function itself that is resulting
in retained access
it is
an actress code is an instance
uh if you accept the other definition
that I'm claiming based on my research
is the slightly less technically correct
definition
you could say that if if you use this
other definition you could say that a
closure is a scope that just doesn't get
garbage collection after its function
has finished run
and that might even be clearer for some
people which is why I don't mind giving
this potentially an accurate definition
but the definition that I believe that I
believe uh is the most correct at this
point unless there's a functional
programming expert who can correct me
which I would welcome
I believe the more correct definition is
that the function that retains access to
that scope is the closure that's the
thing that we're referring to with an
envelope so if inners was not logging B
it would not be the closure that's
correct if inners did not log B it would
not be a closure function and cause uh
it doesn't have access to so and
therefore the outer scope would be
garbage collected because The
Interpreter could detect that there's no
way to talk about B anymore
does it change anything if you pass the
as a parameter function
change anything so you've got an
interstop push function no it doesn't
and I posted it does a great question
does it map does it change matters
does it change matters if
B were an input to the outer function
rather than a local variable I coasted
past this in the in the earlier
discussion I sort of had that that that
slide where an input variable and there
was an arrow and it became a local
variable and I said a local variable is
very similar to a function input
they are an argument to a function an
input to a function
is file rights a local area so there
would be no difference if this was a if
B was something you passed into outer it
would still be a variable of local to
Outer that you had closures go access to
with your inner function
that was actually referring to on
passing it to the inner function
so you define B and outer inner thought
push function parentheses
would that pass it as a copy of the
value and then remove the reference in
the outer
if uh so the question was if we hacked
this code a little bit
so that instead of this
we had B well you had it before you
defined B in the outer right there uh
this is we're we're nearing a conceptual
mistake that that will reveal itself in
the question and if an answer is not
necessary but we'll we'll provide one
anyway okay
what could this possibly mean
why are we keeping this line of code
around
right clearly we have to pass something
in here
right because inners this is inners Sub
Zero right yeah
so we have to pass a value in that we're
giving the name b but we might as well
give it the name X
because it has no relationship with this
you are you were for a moment I believe
imagining that by naming B in the
parameter list we somehow are passing V
into this function
but no passage is happening at best
masking is happening a brand new
variable that is even tighter scope is
masking our visibility into B
that is a really great observation I
wonder if anybody has questions about
what we just sort of
realized there you can actually pass
params at the end of your Anonymous
function that's another great version of
it what if instead
here we passed in B right like that yeah
yeah now what is inners going to store
what you who proposed it what would you
suspect inners the array is going to
have in it
what's that sorry what's your question
so the inner's array right here inners
is created it's an array we then have an
outer function
that mutates it and right here
we call outer so when we call outer
inners is pushed
all of this stuff what is enters going
to store it'll have one element in it
what is it
it's going to have C
okay well C is a variable that
can't be stored in an array
we can store values in Array we cannot
store variables in an array so do you
mean it'll store the same value as what
C referred to
yeah okay what value did C refer to
zero where
where did how would C get into energy so
in this world inner's stored a function
right
inners was being pushed this function
object
sort of strength actually function is
just a string function no no function
isn't the string when you see
f-u-n-c-t-i-o-n
-paren blah blah blah blah and curly
Grace that creates an object just like
two brackets creates an array object
s
it's going to be a function string
it is not technically a string it gets
rendered in the console to look similar
to a string yeah but it's a function
object that can store properties
regardless
at this moment enters in this version of
the code prior to the recommendation
that we pass B in in this version of the
code inters stores one one
element which is a function object
if we were to put
you know if we were to pass some value
here what do you think inners will store
this is the crazy thing
it will return whatever the it will
store enters would store whatever the
function returns
because undefined because this whole
function
if we invoke it immediately we lose
access to the function itself that
function's gone
we get access to what that function
evaluates to since there's no return
value
inner is now store is undefined and this
generates an error so again we have
another attempt valid attempt I Ward
with this stuff when I was first
learning jobs there's got to be a way no
we have another valid attempt but but
that ultimately doesn't work to
circumvent the rule or the the
observation that b is the closest go
barrier
giving it a name here doesn't do
anything calling it here does even worse
stuff
the only meaningful interpretation of
this code is one where B is a closure
scope variable
that's it
okay
yeah obviously interpreter know that it
needs to be around how great question
how did The Interpreter know to keep me
around The Interpreter has very cleverly
implemented uh tracking that watches
every one of your functions and
notices when you when you lose all
references to a function if I lose if I
push if I pop off the winner
right here on this next line I say inner
dot pop
on the next line The Interpreter could
detect that there are no excuse me there
are no more references to
this function because there was only one
to begin with
and that this function was the only
thing it's also keeping track of what
variable who has an idea who has
references who's talking about B well
this function that used to exist was
talking about B but I popped it and it
went into the ether and I didn't store
it in a variable
so the The Interpreter does reference
counting and says hey there's zero
references left for B I'm in a garbage
collection
any other questions about closures
because I got more slides so it's cool
we're gonna call outer again
and your question was what about that so
you call hours
when you
run this in
the function
you initialize some B again ah
interesting okay so let's examine this
what do you expect
this to log in this case notice we ran
outer again which had the effect of
adding a brand new function
to beginner's array but we're still
running the original one
three for Global
right because you're running out of the
first thing but instead you get three to
three one
so
the first one we expect is three for
sure because it's Global it's of course
going to be mutated the last one is C of
course that's going to be one
but notice we are still running inters
Sub-Zero
it's the original inners function that
has access to the same scope as these
did
a new scope was created
for the second run of outer
but that new scope is available to a
different function
inner's bracket one has access to the
brand new scope where B is equal to zero
when I said that a brand new scope is
created every time you call a function
that's what I meant
I meant
that this first run of outer created the
first and only B
which was available to this function
that was stored in either zero
and then we ran outer again creating a
second B that is in a second scope
that second scope is available to the
second version of image stored in inner
one
super confusing
I think it might be time is Quinn still
here yes are you going to show it as one
why yes I am
uh Quinn
do you think you could try to get this
code running that's up here in visual
interpreter because I think it'll help
them to see it step through yep and I
just gotta I had to literally run into a
mommy
it looks like we have five minutes what
time is it
12 54. is that lunch
yeah
well let's see if we can keep it that
way what I'll do is uh I will
I will not stop talking because I think
that because I just can't because I'm
not as a person
I'll keep talking about the demo that
that Quinn and I are going to do uh
but I'll invite you guys to switch to
the work that you have and have the uh
the Tas walking around and uh
you know I'll just speak loud enough to
people in the front here can hear me but
I'll I'll take off the microphone uh and
if you're interested in seeing it Play
Out Below by blow then we'll do that but
before we do we have five minutes to
discuss the um
the
the nature of running inner's sub one
inner sub 1 is the brand new function
that was created here
it's the one that has access to a brand
new V
so my first question all the way in the
back
what would you expect the a the log of a
to yield when we're running errors one
four yes what would you expect the log
of C to be one one what would you expect
the log of B
exactly
the brand new scope created the second
time was only available to enters one
it was not available to enter zero which
is why inner zero continued to use the
old one
when I said when I showed you the
picture of the data store and I and I
started teasing out the difference
between a lexical scope and a
dynamically generated in-memory scope
object it maybe felt a little pedantic
and academic right this is why it's so
important you can't reason about how
your code will run if you aren't
building in your mind a separate little
object a separate data store where
different sets of data are being held
does that make sense
are there any more questions about
closures before we move on
this one's interesting before we leave
if I run inner zero again after having
run enters one
what would you right there with a hat
yeah yes what would you expect it to log
a b and c running into zero yet again
after these lines of code above it would
be five
C would be one
and
P would be
four
you got it
B would be four because we're talking
about the scope that this one was
talking about and this B scope is
incrementing by one
unaffected by the second scope from
Outer that created a scope for inters
one
okay
here's the definition
the function the closure is a function
that retains ongoing access to the
variables that the scope that was
created in
even after outer function calls have
returned
if you want to write one thing down
that's a good thing to write down
if you want to play with some code up
take a picture of the
if you want to play with some code in
your console this is a good code to play
with
you can sort of learn a bit about how
closures work by playing with this code
there's also some closure exercises in
the curriculum so now uh
I would like to
let me do this
I want to make sure that people don't
feel trapped could you do me a favor
everybody stand up
if you would like to start hacking on
stuff and getting help from Tas and
working on this stuff and typing this
code in your browser head toward the
back if you would like to talk about if
you'd like to see visual interpreter uh
uh run through the previous example and
draft these closures scope objects in
real time one line at a time uh come
towards the front that way we can sort
of like segregate and and folks can get
help back there without disturbing us up
here
uh and just have a seat somewhere in the
front two rows if you want to if you
want to see this demo otherwise head
towards the back two roads with the
laptop